Build it.
Draw it.
Play it.
Vsauce!
This is your home for some of the coolest
creations from everyday people.
This is BiDiPi.
BUILD IT
Headmaster Gari Chapidze had a retired plane
transformed into a kindergarten classroom.
He said that he wanted to create a classroom
that kids wanted to go to.
The plane has more that 1500 buttons the kids
can pull, push, flick, and press.
Not only do the kids not want to go home,
there is a waiting list to get into the class.
Botanical artist Maoto Azuma is attempting
to recreate a sustainable bonsai within an
underwater environment.
Deadwood is garnished with java moss to resemble
leaves and then secured into an aquarium.
To recreate the natural cycles within naure,
LED lights and CO2 emissions within the tank
stimulate photosynthesis and a fiction system
keeps it clear of bacteria.
Anthony Michael Simon makes sculptured art
out of actual spiderwebs.
While traveling in Korea he came across a
huge spiderweb and realized that he may be
able to catch the spiders and have them create
webs in his studio.
He sprays a protective coating on the fragile
webs, adds color, and displays them on plastic
rods so that the viewer can see all the intricacies
of the spiders design.
Robbie and Kara Johnson of Below the Boat
have laser cut bathymetric charts available
for sale as wall art that display the landscape
below the water.
The countours are laser cut into sheets of
Baltic Birch and glued together to create
the depths showing off the deep channels,
sharp drop offs and mountainous landscapes.
Choose from a plethora of different underwater
scenes including The great lakes, Long island
sound, cape cod, san juan islands, and many
more.
Check out the website for more.
DRAW IT
Artist Mark Dos Santos re-imagines Gotham
in this series of illustrations that would
have been on the front of the Gotham Evening
Post, if there was one of course.
With a Norman Rockwell influence they show
a glimpse of the characters lives that are
sweet and a little sad.
Located in the valley of Savoy, France Simon
Beck creates snow art by walking through the
snow.
Taking up to 9 hours to create, Beck walks
carefully creating these meticulous patterned
tracks.
Beck is a fan of mathematical patterns that
have different effects when viewed from different
vantage points.
The pieces can even be seen as the snow melts
and reveals traces of the last pattern made
during the last snowfall.
And now for some Judd Apatow tribute art
Illustrator Ale Giorgini created a series
of cult movie posters with all the main charters
in very minimalistic geometric shapes.
The titles and catch phrases of the moves
are also cleverly worked into the background.
PLAY IT
Sound effect master Michael Winslow from Police
Academy and other movies teamed up with DJ
Yoda to create this song made of human sound
effects only.
This is video of a playable record made entirely
out of ice created for Shout Out Louds new
single, Blue Ice
Beet box by Scott Gamer is an electronic drum
set that the player operates by tapping six
fresh beets.
And finally here is a video from Hollerado
for the song Pick Me Up involving a lot of
hot air balloons .
Submit your own BiDiPis as a personal message
here on YouTube.
Or share them with everyone at facebook.com/vsaucegaming.
Click here to listen to bidipi radio.
Music created and submitted by you guys.
Also check out Your BiDiPi - an entire video
dedicated to your creations.
And as always...
thanks for watching.